hey I was gonna press my name is beatta
and welcome to the greatest game of all
time
our cane kids just released no oh my god
yes
sonic dreams so this is a hacked game
for the Dreamcast that they somehow got
their hands on welcome back welcome back
sonic so there's four options we're
gonna check out all of them and um so
excited this game seems so cool and
scary
alright make my sonic quick or let go
I'm gonna let it go there we are our
name is Chrissy meet KY the edge if that
is my god
it changes the song Skyler zip buff
Starfire the immortal Hedgehog that's a
pretty good name Dragon shadow neck
jewel the edge I'm gonna have what what
that sexy outfit preggo mercy the
headshot that's add some oh nice
okay we're changing the legs
I'm really enjoying the freedom of
expression here that they're supplying
with his hedgehogs yeah this looks like
prego Marcy let's take some pictures
another camera angle maybe oh hello
yeah look at that tiny little egg I can
move it oh thank God I could do that
he's dancing he's dancing dance prego
Messi hello God Sonic Sonic you're not
pregnant with your foot Sonic I've told
you many times foots can't be pregnant
oh my god oh my god it keeps going it
keeps going
I'm so sorry sanic hurry up give him
some rings there you go you love rings
don't you your dirty [ __ ] let's try
take all the Rings you're dirty [ __ ] oh
I can print my Sonic
[Music]
[Applause]
Jesus Christ
all right I'll print this later
so that was make my sonic don't worry it
gets better
okay so Eggman origin almost nothing is
known about Eggman origin there is no
surviving documentation from digging
through the code we can tell it was an
MMORPG but few have ever seen past the
title screen few have ever seen past the
title screen okay we're at the title
screen it looks good let's let's damn it
damn damn it what a what a shame okay
I'm glad we did that
well let's move on to Sonic movie making
MJ studio envisioned a movie making
program for players to explore and share
their desires with the rest of the world
their desires very interesting internal
nodes suggest that Sega executives pull
the plug after learning about some of
the sonic sonic movie makers darker
subplots okay so now I can save the
movie to my computer or tweet them nice
I'm excited to try this out yes this
looks legit holy crap
let's make a movie okay so here we are
inside sonic sonic movie maker great I'm
excited
left click to grab okay oh so this is
the set of the latest Sonic fan fiction
looks pretty good oh here's the camera
okay
film school 101 right click focus
left click while focus to record okay
that makes sense let's move this car no
problem there's our hero
hey sanic how you do oh yeah yes yeah
let me film that ass what kind of drugs
did you get sonic it's clearly out of
character oh my god this is gonna be one
[ __ ] nice Sonic fan fiction when
you're done walkthrough they exit to
watching a movie that's a wrap
good job everyone clap it up okay
whoo let's watch this movie just a ball
then the theater sold out Wow um okay
I'm legit scare now oh my god it's prom
night oh my god yes of course
where's the camera get the camera fast
this is gold yeah
that's right that's how I like it
an epic golf ball go in there golf play
it's an ice cream goddamn it get a get
an Oscar he's gonna get a goddamn Oscar
wow it's all that good it's all out a
new genre Phil what's that oh my god
what is happening I'm legit terrified
this is scarier than any horror game
I've ever played what are these noises
coming from this room
there's the camp oh my god oh no they
must be playing Sonic the Hedgehog
without me that tails tails
did he overdose tails he's dead no tails
what do you do oh my god the [ __ ] are
you two doing it might wait they might
filming a sonic porno
I was a gangbang now tails you want in
bro get in there brah
that's right breath you dirty [ __ ] I
always knew tails with that [ __ ] [ __ ]
what that all right you know what why
not let's just go with it we're done
that's a wrap everyone nice penetration
there nice climax gonna [ __ ] sell
this [ __ ] on eBay and I'm gonna make the
millions better as a TV show all right
however you like to watch the sonic
porno it's not up to me oh my god when
will this stop I'm legit terrified
try using e to grab while recording
sanic
[Music]
are you alright are you alright my town
this has to be the weirdest game I have
ever played but it's so arousing I am
fully [ __ ] erect right now Jesus
Christ what that [ __ ] is this huh
or there's the tails tails he came for
you I knew he loved you you just had to
show appreciation that was a good movie
that was a good movie man next scene I'm
legit terrified what's gonna happen next
but oh my god note is he gonna give
birth it's a mess
oh my god yes it's not easy being
pregnant oh my god what's up how did
this get Oh God [ __ ] is happening did
you give birth to that ah let me out of
here oh my god oh my god what is this
you have to break the window maybe holy
[ __ ] did this just become an action
movie sanic you've given birth to the
holy unholy one we need to escape go
tails the camera I am the father now I
don't know how pregnancy works because I
never seen it firsthand but I'm pretty
sure that's not how it works tails yep
no this this is a my coming out of his
vagina it's this supposed to be so next
moist vagina because I don't appreciate
that all right you can do whatever you
want but I'm not going through that [ __ ]
don't tell me I'm inside Sonic's vagina
[ __ ] sake I know I am alright
this has gone too far
oh my god I I literally am look at this
okay
all right you know what I thought I was
sick I thought I was twisted but this is
just too much man
that is that is too much I don't
appreciate that I don't appreciate this
I think this is uncool never asked for
this I never asked to come out of
anyone's vagina now all right
literally quite literally okay you know
what [ __ ] you [ __ ] everyone I'm just
gonna go I'm just gonna go
please be over please no more God no
more how can it get weirder than this
let's wrap up the party thing
nothing nothing in life will ever be the
same after biplane oh my
right so it opened this comic sans
website
I think we have to check out this as
well
even though I'm done I'm [ __ ] done
my roommate sonic my roommate sonic is
an autobiographical game which explores
a human Hedgehog relationships set in
modern apartment complex my roommate
Sonic was a flawless first step into
virtual reality the Sega VR headset was
never released at this game - was very
do I need to play with my uncle is rifts
every [ __ ] alright where is Sonic I
can play with one IVR okay up again this
is so brilliant honestly for [ __ ] sake
[Music]
have you told me your roommate how you
feel about them huh I don't believe you
oh my god it's Eggman what that [ __ ] is
he doing just follow my lead
what what does he want give him the
ticket this is orange all right holy
[ __ ] what happened what ah go for the
kill but Eggman he's my friend take a
dick dammit god dammit okay this is not
at all creepy oh oh
that foot massage babe
oh he's blushing oh my god no no no no
no no no oh god no oh God stare deep
into his eyes I love you I always loved
you you were the only one for me
[Applause]
forgive me
I'm sorry
[Applause]
Oh God
uh-huh like we all aren't we all a sonic
I understand the message my god I hope
this is what you wanted of course of
course all right that's enough
nightmares for one day huge props to our
10 kids or making this awesome game
really really enjoyed it you have to
appreciate our creative they were with
this one especially I really enjoyed
this I really love this really really
cool if you enjoyed leave a like check
out the game I'll leave a link to their
[ __ ] in the description and that's all
for me for now it's always thinking
about watching I seen the next one stay
awesome drips
Josh Josh llama llama llama llama
duck ba da da da